vielleicht kennt ihr das folgenden
phänomen ja auch erinnert euch an dinge
die so gar nicht passiert sind oder aber
ihr seid euch ganz sicher da sein
ereignis ganz anders gewesen ist als es
andere behaupten klar
das könnte reiner zufall sein was aber
ist los wenn sich viele ja sogar einige
hundert menschen falsch erinnern
genau das meint der sogenannte mandela
effekt was diese wirklich äußerst
mysteriöse theorie mit einem
totgeglaubten mann und auch mit star
wars zu tun hat oder ob sie vielleicht
ein indiz für die existenz eines
parallel universums ist klicks und
science fiction
hier gibt's die spannende wissenschafts
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
vielen dank für den themenvorschlag bei
whatsapp die ganze story nahm seinen
lauf als sich die autorin und
selbsternannte geister jägerin fiona
boom mit einigen anderen leuten über den
ehemaligen präsidenten von südafrika
nelson mandela unterhielt ein
freiheitskämpfer der im jahr 1918
geboren wurde und im jahr 2013 gestorben
war
doch der zeitpunkt seines todes ist
tatsächlich der knackpunkt der ganzen
sache denn nicht nur für uns selbst
sondern eben auch viele andere menschen
sind felsenfest in dem glauben dass
mandela eben nicht im jahr 2013 sondern
bereits 30 jahre zuvor gestorben war
bei dem gerade erwähnten gespräch waren
also alle schockiert dass er schon seit
langer zeit tot geglaubte nelson mandela
eben erst viele jahre später gestorben
sein sollte und wie bereits gesagt nicht
nur vier und buben sondern zahlreiche
andere menschen irrten sich in dieser
sache gewalt ist sogar ein zeitungen
wurde darüber berichtet denn auch ein
paar geschichtsbücher sollen mandelas
tod angeblich schon für den zeitraum von
vor mehr als 20 jahren also in den 80er
jahren festgehalten haben und nicht nur
das die menschen konnten sich sogar an
einigen details seines todes erinnern
nämlich dass er beispielsweise einsamen
in einem gefängnis ums leben gekommen
war
ihre behauptung zur folge war auch
niemals südafrikanisches staatsoberhaupt
und dom selbst hatte auch detailreiche
erinnerungen an mandelas
begräbniszeremonie das alles beschreibt
sie auf ihrem blog und bezeichnen das
ganze phänomen als mandela effekt
wissenschaftliche belege gibt es dafür
aber nicht und so kann man den mandela
effekt im großen und ganzen als eine art
verschwörungstheorie bezeichnen darüber
hatten wir ja auch schon mal hier bei
pixum sein
fiction berichtet doch die nelson
mandela story ist nicht das einzige
beispiel dafür dass sich menschen an
fakten erinnern die so eben überhaupt
nicht passiert sind ja dass ich
vielleicht sogar ein großteil der
menschen in genau derselben sache wird
wie zb der berühmte satz aus den star
wars filmen an denen sich ja wohl jeder
von euch erinnert luca war doch
tatsächlich heißt der satz anders denn
darth vader erwähnt den namen seines
sohnes nicht mit einer einzigen silbe
stattdessen lief das gespräch so ab dass
weder one ever told you what have i told
me he told me kill team darth vader know
i'm your faser ja und jetzt kommen die
parallel universen ins spiel
forschungsteams der physik sind schon
seit einiger zeit auf der spur möglicher
parallelwelten auch über dieses
sogenannte multiversum hatten wir ja
erst kürzlich ausführlich berichtet ein
wirklich spannende sache kurz gesagt
gehen manche menschen davon aus dass es
völlig unterschiedliche universum gibt
in denen nicht nur ein anderes physik
herrscht sondern auch unterschiedlich
viele raumdimensionen vorkommen doch wie
genau wird diese these des multiversums
in der physik erklärt zurückzuführen ist
sie auf das standardmodell der
kosmologie nach der sich das all
unmittelbar nach seiner entstehung
ausgedient hat und dies auch immer noch
tut in der fachsprache auch in
fraktionen genannt manche regionen sind
demnach früher zum stillstand gekommen
als andere sie haben sich quasi wie
blasen in kochendem wasser abgesondert
bildlich gesprochen natürlich und so
wäre auch unser universum nur eine blase
neben vielen weiteren dazu der
wissenschaftler allen gut in einem
universum das sich grenzenlos
inflationär ausgehen passiert alles was
überhaupt passieren kann und zwar
unendlich oft jedenfalls würden sich die
verschiedenen universen gegenseitig
beeinflussen auf den mandela effekt
bezogen bedeutet das dass sie das
ereignis für sich quasi eine neue
zeitlinie und somit auch einen eigenen
kosmos für sich eröffnet bei jedem
quanten ereignis das stattfindet
entsteht also ein neuer zeitstrahl und
ein weiteres universum die realität war
ich in gewisser weise somit also ab wenn
sie dann aber auf die wirklichkeit
trifft wird sie durch abweichende
erinnerungen zum ausdruck gebracht sind
die also gleich
die ein indiz dafür dass wir in
verschiedenen varianten existieren
die anhänger des mandela effects
jedenfalls sind von der existenz der
parallel universen überzeugt demnach
basiert dieses mysteriöse phänomen eben
darauf dass diese dinge die in unserer
welt als irrtum geld nicht eine andere
welt den tatsachen entsprechen
die quantenphysik dagegen kann bis heute
nicht wirklich etwas gesichertes zu der
existenz von parallelen universen sagen
der mandela effekt beruht also bisher
keineswegs auf wissenschaftlichen
tatsachen oder fakten eine weitere
mögliche erklärung für dieses phänomen
der falschen erinnerung kommt aus der
naturwissenschaft experten und
expertinnen gehen davon aus dass hierbei
eine fehlfunktion des menschlichen
gehirns vorliegt denn dieses
funktioniert ganz anders als ein
computer oder ein riesiges archiv
vielmehr funktioniert es durch
assoziationen die in einer art
verzweigten netz gespeichert und
abgerufen werden können und na klar die
fehlerquote bei assoziationen die ist
dabei nicht gerade klein und somit
scheint es bislang so als sei die
menschliche erinnerung oftmals
trügerisch und unsicher und durch
verschiedene faktoren wie beispielsweise
der eigenen persönlichkeit und dem
umfeld geprägt auch wenn es vielen
menschen offensichtlich schwer fällt das
zu akzeptieren wenn er auch themen
vorschlagen wollte dann kommt ihr zu
unserer whatsapp community einfach
draufklicken und ihr bekommt einen
newsletter in dem er vor allen anderen
auch vom aktuellen video erfahrt ja und
da drunter oder drüber geht es weiter
mit krieg so bis dann bleibt dran